hang on hang on hang on something isn't
right here first of all let's shrink
this image of me and push me to one side
now we've got a live time lapse of a
real sight and a real project
what's going on guys my name's David
Thomas I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today we're
talking about the design philosophy
behind an architectural project first of
all this project is actually quite
special because I personally considered
buying it and building a family home
however as you'll see by the end of this
video it just wasn't the right fit for a
number of reasons so first of all let's
dive into the design philosophy the
actual site itself and before you even
select a site what you need to be
considering so as you can see this site
is quite large it was about 2 200 square
meters with an easement running
throughout the entire back length of it
the block itself does face North which
is ideal in the Southern Hemisphere and
hence why it was automatically up for
consideration now it does have two
streets one on the Main Street and one
on a side street which is a cul-de-sac
from a design point of view the
cul-de-sac is amazing it's a nice quiet
street it gives you privacy and
protection the main road in itself was
sunk quite far down by having the house
raised so far up and having it
landscaped and actually done properly
you wouldn't have heard too much of this
road noise it was also on the corner of
the main road which again cars would
slow down and therefore the noise impact
wouldn't be as bad as it would
traditionally on a main road first of
all we had the pro of the cul-de-sac we
had the con of the actual main road we
had the pro of the large land size but
we also had the con of that easement so
straight away there were some pros and
cons immediately in the design
consideration of the land itself now the
site had been handed over time and time
and time again it had been sold multiple
times in the last number of years alone
it continuously was planned to be
subdivided and always failed now there's
a number of reasons why it would have
failed my conditions pricing Etc so for
us it wasn't going to be a subdivision
it was simply going to be a one lot
project now yes you could have
subdivided one small block off or two
small blocks and still retained a very
large section of land to be able to
develop a project on but as you start
designing and playing with land you
understand you can do so much more if
you keep it in its entirety and in my
opinion the large land the more valuable
it is in the long run now as you can
also see with the site mesh modeling the
site contained a number of Contours in
itself it was about three different
levels on the site before you were able
to do anything the site itself was
gravel so it wasn't ideal conditions for
building you would have had to build a
sand pad or Elevate the house off the
ground slightly my ideal preference in
this situation would have been a sand
pad lift that house another meter into
the air which would have been premium to
get even nicer views of the forest
having these Contours allows for design
creativity and freedom so a site like
this is actually quite intriguing and
interesting to an architect like myself
because you're not just designing on a
flat box now flat boxes have their time
they have their place and you can do
some incredible things on them but when
you have some Contours when you have
some slopes when you have some character
to a site it really adds value to the
overall design and gives you a great
starting point to actually think
creatively around the entire project so
this was a huge benefit in my opinion
most people would have looked this site
going it is not flat I don't want to
touch it whereas as an architect you go
this is amazing we can do so many
creative things with this space so the
Contours and the ground conditions
weren't too much of a problem I knew for
a fact we could easily Rectify all of
these land conditions during the site
preparation works and it wouldn't be an
issue whatsoever now as part of a design
consideration when you're looking at a
project and looking at a block as an
architect I always look at the greater
surroundings the context and the
plannings game itself it is all well and
good that your block is perfect but what
happens around you is critical as well
so for example this block overlooked the
forest which was incredible it was going
to be a beautiful breathtaking view
however what we didn't realize when we
first started looking at it is that
there was minutes of the meeting in the
council to convert this entire Forest
Area into a new land subdivision and a
week later when we're still considering
this block that actually passed Council
and it was no longer going to be a
beautiful Forest they were going to
clear it gut it and build just Urban
infill so the value of this property for
us more so because it was a nice Outlook
was significantly diminished very
rapidly so understanding the planning
policies the council schemes and what's
happening in the area is just as
critical as understanding what that
block is and what the regulations are
for that block specifically what I
failed to mention is between that week
where we started looking in the project
and the next week where we found out the
council approved this land clearing I'd
actually started designing something on
this block to see it was feasible this
is something that I do for every single
block that we look at first of all I'll
do a quick mud map of where the rooms
could go where it could be laid out and
how the design could actually flow I
don't spend a lot of time on this it is
very rough it is very quick for instance
this probably took me about an hour to
model the entire entire site to actually
get some massing on the site and go
would this work could I actually develop
this idea further does it have enough
room for everything that we are seeking
from this brief and what are the
limitations of this site by being able
to quickly mud map this within an hour
isn't going to lose you the sale of the
property in any way it might in some
cases where it is a very hot property
and it sells instantly but where it is
something that it isn't going to go off
the market too quickly you have the time
you have the freedom to actually do the
research now obviously I'm in the
industry this is what I do all day every
day for a living so I know exactly what
I'm doing and it doesn't take me very
long and for others it may take a
substantial amount of research and time
to actually start plotting these things
out mapping it out and understanding
where the site can go and how the site
operates if the massing and the initial
site feasibility pans out and it becomes
a viable site well then usually I just
leave it at that and go okay this is a
site worth exploring yes it meets our
brief yes we can look at purchasing
block or simply advising my client that
the same thing yes it is a good viable
site in other times when I have a little
bit of spare time and I just simply
enjoy designing and creating I will go
ahead and completely model this entire
project to what I foresee could be one
variation of the final image in this
case for me I thought there was quite a
lot of opportunity here to develop a
beautiful family home that is North
facing has most of the sun throughout
the entire day almost all on a single
level and yet to still be able to have
so much more for that property to be
able to make it much more valuable
personally speaking now because the land
size was so large you could fit a
beautiful family home on it you could
fit a small pool in there you could even
fit a tennis court if you wanted to now
we also love to grow our own vegetables
we love to grow our own food so there
was this optimal area to use that
easement as a beautiful vegetable garden
now eventually you could turn this into
whatever you wanted and it may not grow
as well in that soil so you'd have to do
quite a lot of extensive research into
that area however the feasibility
started to actually shape together but
now you might be thinking I've just said
all these positive things about this
block it's met my general feasibility
study why did I turn around and go well
it's probably not the right block for us
well first of all let's break it down
again it is on a main street that Main
Street is quite loud and quite busy The
View that you are paying for and
actually expecting to see you for the
next lifetime is going to quickly
disappear because of urban infill this
has been approved by the council it is
going to go ahead at some point in time
if it happens in one year five years ten
years I don't know but it is almost
certainly going to happen at some point
in time the contouring of the site next
is amazing and is something that I look
for when actually purchasing a block
however because the contouring just
isn't right there is a significant
amount of land Works which would push
the project well and truly outside of
our budget now you obviously have two
options you can decrease your scope or
increase your budget so there is
viability still to bring that back into
scope and make it viable what then goes
through your head is how much you're
actually spending on this property where
is the property located and are you over
capitalizing just because you're
designing a family forever home and
something that will last a lifetime
hopefully for everybody involved in the
project doesn't mean you're ever going
to make your money back now for most
people this might not be a consideration
but for me it is a huge consideration
because if we ever do go sell with this
property I would love for it to actually
generate some sort of return or to even
break even now because the area the
property was located in there was zero
possibility of this land and this
property design ever being valued at
what we're going to spend so we would
have been significantly out of pocket
when we went to sell this property last
but not least the actual property itself
the suburb it's zoned in is in the wrong
school catchment so when you're looking
for a family home you're looking for all
sorts of things including proxy meter
hospitals proximated schools proximity
to shopping centers daycare centers
Parks playgrounds sporting facilities
all of those life amenities this one had
most of it perfectly there but it just
fell short on too many key criteria the
last factor of course was that the price
of the property now generally speaking
long turn the price the property was
fantastic land always goes up however
the price of the property of what we
were willing to pay for it for the
overall budget was just a little bit too
high we didn't see the full value due to
the amount of Earthworks site works and
preparation Works to make this site
exactly what we needed again that is
taken into the context that this
property itself will always be over
capitalized for what we're going to do
so overall the price of land just makes
the Thai project completely unfeasible
and unviable anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video I
hope you enjoyed the time lapse on the
side to see this beautiful project
finished but unfortunately never built
if you have any comments please leave
them down below and make sure you hit
that subscribe button whilst you're down
there there's some awesome links in
description as well if you have a little
bit of free time feel free to check them
out join our Discord group and chat with
other Architects and students around the
world just as passionate as you like I
said that is all for me so I'll see you
next Monday